how are your Lexi greetings from Red
Square I am sitting right in Red Square
at our set it's a beautiful night here
in Moscow I'm waving to the Kremlin and
maybe to mr. Putin hey how's it going is
it well if anybody does come by
shirtless on horseback during this
conversation you can interrupt me at any
point in time
Alexei glorious glory would it not so
what what do you think of let's start
with the today's events where Japan
moves on because they had fewer yellow
cards than Senegal that's a Fairplay
tiebreaker do you think that is a fair
way to have a tiebreaker in the World
Cup alexei well i was actually having a
conversation with someone who was
arguing that it should be based on
encouraging more attacking and creative
type of plays and therefore it should be
on i don't know most shots or the most
corners or something like that but the
other argument it is you don't want to
reward cheaters and one thing that I've
heard over the years when it comes to
you know especially Americans when it
comes to soccer is you know the diving
and the embellishment and it really
tries people crazy and in essence what
you're doing is you're you're saying
that they're cheaters and so in in this
instance what you are doing is rewarding
people for not cheating and I don't
think that that's necessarily a bad
thing but I mean if you are Senegal
which was a wonderful team and they
entertained us and they were attacking
it's got to be incredibly painful to go
out on something like this a historic
thing that's never happened before and
they're going home based on the the
amount of yellow cards and red cards
that they can what about this idea here
since we all really obviously know
England and Belgium are having at it
right now and each of them benching
their best player because they've
already moved through we already know
Japan is gonna be taking on England
they're Belgium in the round of 16 at
2:00 p.m. Eastern Time in rostov we
already know that Japan's there so if it
would have been either Japan or Senegal
what about flying both those sides to
the city where they're gonna be playing
in a couple days and having penalty
kicks I mean I know that sounds
ridiculous but why not doing something
like that instead of just
yellow cards Alexa yeah I know I mean
look I know we joke about these
different things but and there's so much
tradition involved in this sport but
keep in mind that we're also seeing a
World Cup that is using video assistant
refereeing for the first time so there
has been an evolution evolution it
doesn't mean you want to have a
completely different game but all sports
have changed all sports have changed
with the times with the change of
technology and with the desire to do
different things so it comes to soccer
because it's such a it has been such a
defensive game the way that it's
refereed all that kind of stuff has
changed so well you know wow that may be
that may be something you know that that
people laugh about look I think anything
that you can do to make any any type of
sport certainly a World Cup more
interesting more entertaining more drama
I don't know how you're gonna have more
John because we've already just did this
group stage had it had incredible drama
I'm up for it I am impressive I like to
try to contain this and things that
haven't been done before Alexi Lalas
joining us here from Red Square live on
the Rich Eisen show top of our number
three in the mid state just it has been
exhilarating it has been so exciting the
number of late goals the number of
exciting chances that we have seen it is
just been I've been back there for you
guys I have a work perception here just
just sitting here doing this Groundhog
Day existence Groundhog Day in the world
but I don't have an idea of what's going
on back there uh you know I'm I'm into
it we're talking about it here we get we
get tweets from our viewers and
listeners saying talk more about it I
don't you know I'm talking to more
people who don't really follow sports
all that much you know parents of kids
in schools you know the of our kids in
schools mutual parents I mean that I
don't normally talk to about it
I mean it really is it I don't know how
it's capturing the nation to be honest
with you but the the Germany Sweden
numbers were through the roof that got
me off the couch I mean that that that
final goal and yet Germany's still out
Alexi who do you think is is the
favorite now with Germany out to take it
well you know I think we're we're
watching a Belgium team right now albeit
a Belgian team that made a bunch of
changes and I think there's a lot of
people that are looking to them as a
real as a real contender Croatia storms
their group stage and I think it's just
a really solid 11 there's really no no
no weaknesses when it comes when it
comes to that team you know and then
you're going to have some of your usual
suspects and obviously the surprise and
you know the the introspection now
that's going on from a germany
perspective is finale I'm not sure
there's a lot of people out there that
pick Germany to go out or certainly it's
German you go out in this way and it is
a epic failure considering how great
they were considering the depth that
they have and what they have been over
the last not just four years but last
for eight years in all tournaments not
just the World Cup so there's but you
know you mentioned this drama that I
think people are gravitating to whether
it's the big star struggling or big
stars coming through or big teams having
problems or smaller teams going through
there's something there seems to be
something every single day on the field
off the field you know Diego Maradona in
the sessions I mean all this is going on
it's big tip that keeps on giving and
from a television perspective it makes
it so good because the content is just
generated on a continual basis that
gives us something to talk about so I'm
glad people are waking up I'm glad
people are watching it's disingenuous
for me or anybody else just say that it
doesn't matter the demesne the US men's
team isn't here it hurts
it's an incredible failure and it's a
wasted opportunity but America is a
soccer playing nation America has a
soccer culture and while the men's team
is not here at the World Cup it doesn't
mean that America is not enjoying and at
this World Cup what do you think Alexi
Lalas of the grief Landon Donovan's
getting for his Wells Fargo sponsorship
love of Mexico Alexi he's getting paid
he's getting paid you know I'm doing I'm
doing the same thing and I you know I've
been supporting Mexico before anybody
even hatred said that they would you
know want to want to jump on that so and
I get it I understand people are going
to scream and yell but it's one thing to
get paid for doing something that you
don't believe it's another thing to do
something that I was doing before and
then they came to me and and Landon you
know I truly built that I've known when
Atlanta for a long time I truly believe
that he is sincere in this support I can
only talk to you about how I feel mm-hmm
I I want Mexico to do well
and that doesn't and if you don't want
Mexico to do well that's fine knock
yourself out that doesn't make you
though any more genuine or authentic or
dare I say it American because you are
BM at least opposed to even the notion
of succour ting our biggest rival it's
it's okay guess what i mean i remind you
yet again I don't have a team in this
World Cup so I'm looking for a team and
our neighbors to the south while they
are incredible you know when it comes to
the rivalry and if the US was ever
playing Mexico in anything let alone
soccer I'm supporting the u.s. the u.s.
isn't here and so my gift to them and
they have earned it and they deserved it
is my support for them and I'm not going
to speak for Landon or we all take grief
I take it every single day that's the
way that it goes but I think it comes
from an insecurity ultimately and and a
belief that an elitism that you are
somehow a better fan or as I said more
American if you take this stance there's
no chance in hell I could ever look for
my rival well in terms of adopting a
squad we here on the show Aleksey me and
my two on-air compadres my on-air
producer Chris Brockman and Mike Dell
2fo the audio executive of our program
we all drew names out of a hat all 32
nations we put it into a hat and we drew
we drew teams and adopted this team the
and and whoever whoever's team lasts
longest in this tournament wins and I'd
like to get your take on who you think
is in a better position as we're
currently talking here okay Alexi my my
okay my my compadre Chris Brockman drew
Argentina who now takes on France and he
was sweating bullets he had quite the
group play sweat I did yesterday with my
I'm the land and Donovan of this I drew
Mexico out of the Hat and my buddy Mike
tell two photos Japan which thanks to
the Fairplay because they they were more
civil they they moved on who do you
think with Japan facing the winner of
Belgium in England who do you think in
Mexico taking on Brazil has the best
chance of lasting longest
okay so I think it was Mike you said is
screwed with your pants that's not
happening okay and then me with Mexico
and Argentina what do you think what do
you think okay so and this is where it
gets really interesting
so this Argentine arts in time hot mess
of dysfunction is something that you
can't take your eyes off you know kind
of like a car crash but the soccer God's
work in mysterious ways
I think this is not a good team and yet
coming up against a France that has yet
to play up to their incredible potential
but not not in the way that our G Tina
is as flattered to deceive I still think
that France is going to find a way to
expose all the weakness and all the
dysfunctions that that are human though
so I think I think I think you're okay
with that one if you have France but you
have Argentina so I think you're in
trouble and then the other was what
Mexico I've got Mexico against Brazil oh
you got mad yeah I know okay so I think
actually yeah I think Mexico actually
matches up well with Brazil I we were
having an argument on set here i I think
that Mexico playing against the team
that wants the ball and wants possession
of all because Mexico doesn't really
want the ball they want a counter-attack
and we saw against Sweden a team that
sat back in Mexico didn't what know what
to do when they were given the ball and
they had to actually play an attack and
have most of the possession so I think
it's actually a really good matchup but
they are going to have to have an
absolutely perfect game to get by a
Brazil that I think into individually
better than them and as a team as better
than but if that doesn't always mean
that that team wins oh man I think I
think the Mexico beating Brazil you're a
better chance okay Alexi Lalas like a
that likes me to through and we have a
new fantasy team name of what is that
Argentine hot mess of dysfunction that's
great why is it so much fun to watch it
so much it has been is been great Alexi
and last one for you this is apropos of
nothing as you know I'm a follically
challenged individual and I watched with
such
I guess jealousy of these guys who run
and run and run and even the referees -
that's all they do there so they're
there they're obviously physically fit
but somehow some way their hair never
gets messed up the soccer part the
soccer hair never gets messed up
Perry Cain is just a perfect example
what are they using their hair Aleksei
what what what do you yeah
so this is what has happened in this
game I said I come from a time where we
certainly concentrated on the hair but
the actual hair care products used while
we were playing were minimal it's much
more organic dare I say I hippie a type
of approach when it came to the hair
nowadays it's it's much more cost and
and and the amount of product that is
going into it and an industrial-strength
I mean to look beyond it because it's
gotta last the entire game and you're
sweating and as you mentioned there's
different elements I am amazed sometimes
that the part doesn't move and the
creases don't move it is glorious
sometimes to watch just somebody's hair
there's there's a guy for example on on
trance named Olivia Giroux who's it was
a very good player a great player but a
good player but his hair alone makes him
a great player I mean just just has on
the top of his head and the product that
he has I mean I wonder how much how
early these guys have to get to the the
locker room or wherever they're coming
from in order to do this there must be a
whole new way an element of preparing a
team you have to factor in this time for
the hair care product regimen that
whether it's a Jew or a Christian or
novel or anybody out there is it is
quite amazing and it's mesmerizing I
agree with you that so is there hair
doping is that what you think going on
in FIFA's their hair dope there is very
little movement I would not put it past
some of these guys to be doing some
things that are a little bit beyond the
pale okay I'm not accusing anybody
because I don't want to do that and I am
sitting here at the Kremlin raised the
face of the Kremlin and I was doing
everything I say I'm just saying okay
that when I look at this hair something
does it make sense all right the science
of it does not work No
you know I'll leave that there as I said
I have to be very clear
I understand Aleksey love the chat let's
chat when you get back home okay sounds
good guys I appreciate a guy that's
Alexi Lalas the Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on audience